DAS NOBEL: Welcome to session
Life After COVID-19, How
to Prepare for Economic,
Social, and Recovery
Efforts in the Marketplace.
So I have my colleague,
Nick Whitney,
and myself will be walking you
through some of the use cases
as we learn in the industry.
And hopefully this
will help you go
through some
thought-provoking conversation
as you look to solve some of the
challenges in your workforce.
So my name is Das Nobel.
I'm the co-founder
and CEO of MTX Group,
and I am based out
of Frisco, Texas.
I've been a lifelong
[INAUDIBLE] technology
engineer and also an architect.
I enjoy working in
the cloud technology.
Especially I embraced
Google Cloud platform
for several years and enjoyed
talking to government agencies
and also private sector
leaders to make sure
that we can solve some of
the real-world challenges.
Nick.
NICHOLAS WHITNEY: Thank
you, everybody, for joining.
Hi.
My name's Nick Whitney.
I am a co-founder
and CIO at MTX Group.
I've been a cloud architect
for about 15 years,
and I've been in software for
as long as I can remember.
And I enjoy really using
software and cloud technologies
to be able to solve
business problems.
DAS NOBEL: Great.
Thanks, Nick.
So before we get
started, there are
four topics that we'd like
to highlight in this session.
Hopefully these are
meaningful and relevant
for some of the challenges
you're looking to solve,
whether you're in
government agencies
or in a private sector
as decision makers.
Now, there is one thing
that we're very aware,
and that is the COVID era
has been unpredictable.
And as part of the different
stages of the COVID era
and the way that we're
looking to reopen the economy,
but do it in a
safe manner, there
are a number of challenges
that are coming up.
There is no recipe for success.
These are some of the
conversations that we continue
to have, collaborate,
and oftentimes co-create
some of the solutions while
partnering with organizations
like Google Cloud technology
or some other cloud
technologies and also partner
with a company like MTX
to see how we can
innovate in this space
in this unpredictable time.
Today's conversation
will focus on how
to reopen workforce safely.
And then we're
going to talk about,
what are some of the
underlying challenges
that we're seeing as part of the
lockdown and social distancing
that are popping up while
protecting the children that
are most vulnerable
in our society?
We'll focus on what
have we learned
as part of quality of life
with this remote workforce?
Are there things that we can
apply going forward after COVID
and make sure that we can
increase productivity?
And how do we do it with the
metrics that we can justify?
There are meaningful
changes that
could be brought as part
of this acceleration
in the the digital world.
And then we'll wrap
it up with insight
into how can Robotic Process
Automation, as known as RPA,
can help government
agencies or private sector
really embrace their
remote workforce?
Minimize some of the
mundane laborous tasks
that needs to be done
manually, or it requires
folks to be in the office.
How can we bring some
operational efficiency?
Well, let's get started as we
dive into these four topics.
Before we do dive into
these four topics,
a quick introductions about MTX.
MTX is a global
implementation partner
that provides services
for government agencies
and private sectors
around the world.
We take in in zero
failed projects
in the past six-plus
years, while delivering
450 projects for our clients.
MTX has 420 family members
within our organization,
and we're a very
culture-centric organization.
We take pride in
investing in people.
And then when we
invest in people,
we know that they'll
invest in the clients.
They'll invest in some of the
innovative activities that
takes place to make sure that
we continue to bring solutions
very rapidly.
Speaking about bringing
solutions very rapidly,
in this COVID era, one
thing we have learned
is that we don't
necessarily have
time for projects that could
take six months, seven months.
Things need to be done
in weeks, if not in days.
So when we are called to
listen to some of the use
case of the government agencies,
we're having discussions,
how can we solve problems in a
matter of three to four days?
We [INAUDIBLE]
something quickly,
deploy it, and
really then iterate
through those solutions
with the rich feedback
from the end users.
That's the summary of MTX
and how we like to innovate.
Let's jump into the four
topics for today's agenda.
The first is the
workforce reentry.
Whether you are working for the
government agencies as a CIO
or deputy commissioners
or commissioners,
or leading a private sector
entities as a CIO or decision
makers, or whether you
are parents, teachers,
or union leaders that are
really looking to see,
how can we go back
to school safely?
As I mentioned, there
is no single path
in the way you can go back
and create a safe environment.
This is a meaningful
conversation
that we need to continue
to have as we continue
to look to our technology
to support us in creating
a safe work environment.
So let's take a look at what MTX
has been doing with government
agencies and private sector.
We have seen that entities with
a thousand employees or 5,000
employees or 20,000 employees,
up to 400,000 employees,
as they are looking to
reopen their workforce,
there is a significant
question that
needs to be answered by the HR
team and the leadership team.
Is that, how do we
ensure a safe environment
for the workforce to come back?
How do we ensure a safe learning
environment for children?
There are a number of modules
MTX developed within the Google
Cloud technology.
The first component is
that wellness survey.
As part of our
mobile applications,
there is a wellness
survey that is deployed.
It consists of a
set of questions
that can be configured
to the needs
of the specific organization.
And as part of the
survey, it is required
that employees or children
must fill this out before they
go back into this environment.
And as part of the survey,
if they do get a pass sign,
then that can be utilized
to have a green light
to go back to the
workforce on a daily basis.
Now, it is recommended
that individual
must take this survey daily to
make sure that there is a pulse
check on the well-being
of the individuals
and also making
sure that folks that
are coming to the
workforce and we're
creating a safe
environment for them.
Whether you're running multiple
[? ships ?] as part of a global
operations, this solution will
help you manage [? ships. ?] It
will also help you manage your
identity as part of the reentry
into the workforce, where we
minimize touching different
devices within offices
and create those identity
solutions, whether you're
looking to do a facial
recognitions and that touches
with the applications as part
of validating employees
versus visitors,
these are all enabled
[? 18 ?] hour solutions.
In addition to that, we
have a reservation module
that allows employees to reserve
specific cubicle or conference
rooms ahead of time before
coming to workforce.
It enables workforce
to really provide
a safe distance, social
distancing in place
to making sure that whether
you're looking for a 25% or 40%
capacity as part of
your workforce reentry,
you can manage the capacity,
and the reservation
will honor those
settings to make sure
that there is a proper
distance within the offices.
And there is another advantage
to this reservation too.
When you are looking at
cleaning the office environments
on a regular basis, if you
maintain the reservation
process, this information could
be provided to the cleaning
services companies to make sure
that they do thorough cleaning
at the end of the day
so the environment is
safe for the next day
for your workforce.
Overall, we do provide
a command center
using BigQuery and [INAUDIBLE]
to visualize the information.
Whether you are HR or specific
business unit leaders,
you'll have full visibility
whether your workforce is fully
compliant, if there are risks.
And all of this
could be bubbled up
within the Google
Cloud technology
as part of our solutions.
Nick, you have been
working in COVID ecosystems
with different
government agencies.
What else would you
like to add as part
of your experience you're seeing
with the workforce reentry?
NICHOLAS WHITNEY:
Thank you, Das.
One of the items that we've
seen that has been prevalent
throughout all of the
engagements that we've had
is that more people are
trying to do more with less.
There has been restrictions
on availability
and budgets and other areas.
And essentially
we want to ensure
that we're able to provide
the best level of service
that we can and leverage
the tools that we can
to make this easy on everybody.
We've seen a big push to
be able to bring people
back to the workforce safely.
And the survey tool allows
us to use near-real-time data
to capture their ability to
rejoin the workforce safely
without having additional
risks presented
to everybody else who's also
trying to rejoin the workforce.
As we look at this
data, there's a lot
of risk around the
security of the data.
So we also need to make
sure the systems are going
to be performing,
that they're secure,
and that we can make the
appropriate business decisions,
whether we actually have
access to the underlying data
or if we just have access
to aggregate data, whatever
the appropriate
business goals are.
Ultimately, those systems still
need to protect the people.
And we, then, can make
the business decisions
to protect them as they
rejoin the workforce safely.
Das.
DAS NOBEL: Absolutely,
and love the fact
that he mentioned being
able to do more with less.
Having solutions that
has been rolled out
for multiple agencies
or private sectors,
we can bring solutions in a
very cost-effective manner,
and then they can be
rolled out within 48 hours.
So we'll absolutely love to
have this conversation and then
showcase how we can innovate
with Google Cloud technology.
All right, so thank you, Nick.
We'll jump into the next topic,
and that is child welfare.
As part of this social
distancing and lockdown,
there is troubling numbers
that are popping up
in our society where
kids being stuck at home,
not being able to
go back to school,
or not being able to collaborate
with their friends and peers.
There are challenges
at the household
where the number of children
abuse and neglect are rising.
And they will continue to rise.
If you are a decision maker
within the government agencies,
you may be challenged with, what
can we do in the short term?
[INAUDIBLE] during the
long-term strategy?
What can you do where some
of the solutions [INAUDIBLE]
be rolled out, whether you
are supporting the child care
agencies, whether you are
supporting the foster care
agencies, the foster parents.
What can be done to
make sure that we're
creating a safe
environment for children?
Well, let's dive into some
of the specific things what
MTX has built within the
Google Cloud technology
to make sure that you
do not necessarily
have to reinvent the wheel.
We can absolutely
repurpose our solutions
to make sure that things
that has been rolled out that
are meaningful and provide
meaningful value to the society
in keeping children safe.
Whether you're looking at the
foster parent or child care
providers, we are able
to provide our child
protective services
solutions that it
has a comprehensive
solutions, including oversight
into the different
subsidy program
to make sure that if
people or foster parents
are really abusing children,
they should not be subsidized,
and there's a way to bubble
out those information.
So we absolutely
recommend taking a look
at having assistance.
We're way past doing things on
paper or an Excel spreadsheet.
Let's embrace the
cloud technology
that has been built by MTX.
Within the Google
Cloud technology tool,
they have those visibility.
There are an awful lot of
data that are out there,
but I believe that
we can take the data
and provide meaningful
informations.
We can lead that into
actionable insights
and then have real
change in the society
and keeping children safe.
In addition to that, making
sure that whether it's
a foster parent or
the daycare providers
are really being compliant and
providing a safer environment.
MTX built a background
record check application
that can be rolled out to
these different use cases
and making sure that
we're managing risk.
As part of the
managing risk, we need
to be able to
understand, what are
some of the regulatory
statutes that we need to make
sure that we are compliant?
And also making sure
that we're enforcing
those on a regular
basis and be able to do
some of the inspection visit
using cloud technology,
such as Google Meet.
And whether you schedule remote
visits or in-person visits,
there's certain ways you can
use this technology as you go
and be able to have those
informations bubble out so you
can have an informed
decision-making process as part
of your agencies.
Now, we do look at creating a
safer environment for children,
whether it is
back-to-school solutions
or really creating a solution
for the essential workforce,
whether they can put
their kids in a daycare.
All of these
solutions are really
relevant in how you
could promote and have
a meaningful,
insightful informations
to make informed decisions
in the way you digitize
and transform.
Now, it is common sense
to say that, well,
why wouldn't we create a safer
environment for children?
Well, it's really difficult when
you had the paper-based systems
or really antiquated
systems or systems that
do not talk to each other.
Our comprehensive child
protective solutions really
enables decision
makers to have insight
into the different activities
across different business units
and bubble up informations
is that if providers
or foster parents are
really breaking the rule
and creating an unsafe
environment for children,
then some of the subsidy
programs could be frozen,
and then certain
penalty could be
imposed to make sure that we
continue to create a safer
environment for the children.
So let's take a look at
the next topic, which
is the quality of life.
Whether you are decision
makers at a CIO level
or deputy commissioners
or business unit leaders,
there's a constant conversation.
It's that, is it safe for
us to go back to work?
Or how should we really
roll out the strategy?
There's a meaningful
conversation to have.
And that is that do you need
to rush in your strategy to put
everyone back into workforce?
What are some meaningful
insight in terms
of, is there benefits having
folks working remotely?
And if you do, what
are some of the things
you need to be aware of?
We strongly recommend using
the Google Cloud technology
to create a collaborative
environment,
a connected community.
The research has
shown that when you
create a connected community
for the remote workforce using
the right tool and
technology for collaboration,
you create a happy workforce.
When you create a
happy workforce,
there is a direct correlation
to increase in productivity.
So we strongly
recommend that as you
are dealing with this
unpredictable time,
to look at the cloud
technologies such as Google
Cloud Platform to make
sure that we can enable
those collaboration tools,
including the Google Meet,
to make sure that your
employees feel connected.
The next, you are going
to be looked to accelerate
the digital transformation.
This year with the
COVID responses,
it kind of forced us
to really look at this
and really accelerate all
of our needs in that aspect.
The good news is you do have
some Care Act funding that will
expire at the end of the year.
Some of you have
already accelerated
those digital transformation.
There are some of
those other technology
that you may have that you can
potentially bring to the Google
Cloud technology
and also subsidize
those with this Care
Act funding and support
your remote workforce.
As part of that
process, do set up
some metric in
terms of whether you
care about the throughput,
work-life balance,
or connected community
that increases
productivity in the workforce.
Have those meaningful
metrics that are defined.
And also rules are built
out using our solutions
within Google Cloud technology
using BigQuery and [INAUDIBLE]
so you can visualize at
the organization level
or at the business unit level.
And this will ensure
that as you're
supporting the remote
workforce or there
is an incremental slow process
to get back to normalcy,
there is a way you can
support the quality of life
for your remote workforce
using Google technology.
With that being said,
we're on the last topic.
And Nick, I'll turn it over
to you for the robotic process
automation.
NICHOLAS WHITNEY:
Thank you, Das.
As we look at the theme
of doing more with less,
we have a lot of ability to
improve our worker experience
at the same time that we
reduce the amount of effort
that we're putting into
a standardized workforce.
We really want to
be able to automate
our repetitive actions.
We want to be able to
increase our quality,
and want to be able to
reduce the human error that's
associated with
these manual actions.
So we want to minimize
any manual tasks
and start to be
able to move those
into system-based workflows.
As we look at the bots
that are available to us
or that we can build, we have
a lot of areas of improvement.
Finance has the ability to
streamline their AP and AR
including things like vendor
onboarding, where they
may no longer be able to
bring people into an office
to be able to sign paperwork
and be able to actually handle
that in person.
They now need to be able
to do this remotely.
So we can set up
the bots that allow
them to streamline this process
that would have historically
been done on paper.
As we look at the
approvals, we want
to be able to automate those.
Those are no longer again
going to be stamped.
They're not going to be in ink.
We want to be able to
move those into a system.
And as we look at HR, especially
with some of the challenges
that come out from COVID of
perhaps [? standing up ?]
call centers for responding
to issues that they may not
historically have
handled, we want
to be able to automate
the onboarding,
orchestrate the systems that
need to be put together.
As we look at doing that
automation of the onboarding,
we can increase
our responsiveness
and improve our
worker experience
by using bots to be
responsive to what
comes back from those people.
If we have forms that
need to be set out,
if we have signatures
that are required,
we can ensure that
those processes are
streamlined, efficient,
and providing a good worker
experience to people who may
not have as much experience
with those forms.
As we look at these
tools, there's
also a great example here of
being able to use the AI tool.
One of the AI tools
that we suggested
is a Maverick AI tool, which is
our internal Maverick platform.
This has been built on
a Google Cloud platform
and allows us to reduce the
amount of effort that is spent
on tasks that are lower value.
Those tasks can instead
be done by the platform
and allow us to do something
like scanning documents
to ensure that they are
accurately filled out
and sending them back
out to the people
if they're not completed.
And whatever rules-based
platform action is,
we need to be able to follow up.
This allows us to focus our
people's time and energy
where there's higher value.
And instead of having them
scan 100% of the documents,
they may only need
to be involved
with 20% of the documents.
They can review those and
be far more efficient.
Das, is there anything
you want to add?
DAS NOBEL: Yeah, absolutely.
I think, Nick, your
organization at MTX
really leads the whole
AI platform initiatives.
And I get all these
warm and fuzzy
feeling when I see that
some of these bots of some
of those technologies
you're bringing in
and oftentimes educate
us is that as a leader,
as we're looking
to really minimize
some of the manual tasks, and
how can the bots be utilized?
Now, as a decision maker,
if you had the funding
to really go through the
digital transformation
and invest in the
Google Cloud technology
and replace your
existing systems, great.
If you don't have the
luxury, we take a look at it
in the RPA [INAUDIBLE]
with Maverick AI platform,
how can you really solve
some of the challenges?
Nick, let's talk about--
there's a lot of folks who
will talk about, well, AI
is buzz words.
We are seeing some
real-world examples
and we're solving
real-world problems
for government agencies
and the private sector.
If I'm a CIO, what can I look
toward in terms of preparations
in solving some of my
challenges using AI?
How do I start?
NICHOLAS WHITNEY: So
what we like to do
is we like to start with a
journey map of if we were
able to look into the future and
say, what does a perfect state
look like?
We want to understand
that vision
and understanding
that business goal.
What that allows us to do, then.
Is kind of look at what is
maybe a low-hanging fruit.
Sometimes things
look like they're
going to be more
complex, but it's
something you could
actually do in a far more
efficient fashion.
Allows you to pilot
the functionality,
ensure that you're
comfortable with it,
start to build
that all over time.
It doesn't necessarily
need to be that we
boil the ocean on day one.
We can solve a single
business problem,
free up some resources,
and then move on
to the next business problem.
Ultimately, that
kind of evaluation
of the security,
evaluation of the workflow,
and starting out in a measured
and controlled fashion
is something that we've
seen be very successful
and start to really
free up those resources
to move on to the
next area where
there is better focus and better
area of improvement for us.
DAS NOBEL: Yeah, absolutely.
And thanks, Nick.
And obviously
privacy and security
are the topmost priority
for your R&D team
as you continue to
innovate in that space.
I do welcome any questions
or any conversation
from other CIOs
or decision makers
to really connect
with Nick Whitney
and see how we can
help you as you
look to migrate into the
Google Cloud technology
and also utilize our
Maverick AI platform in some
of the decision-making process.
This will be the end
of our presentation.
I appreciate you spending
the time with us.
Hopefully you found these topics
to be thought-provoking as you
have conversation with your
colleagues, with your peers,
or even at a dinner
table in the way
that we're all addressing
some of these COVID-related
challenges.
My name is Das Nobel, and I'm
the co-founder and CEO of MTX.
NICHOLAS WHITNEY: Nick Whitney.
I'm the co-founder
and CIO of MTX.
Thank you.